l'angoissé de la feuille blanche ça
paralyse au début j'allais chez mallarmé
lui même le disait la feuille blanche
dont la blancheur repoussent leur poche
est à la fois l'angoissé l'excitation de
laquelle amar 6 1
et pour cela ils ont été gâtés les
questions n'ont pas manqué à cette
petite troupe de philosophes écrivains
ou qui l'espace d'une matinée rejoint
les potaches les sujets cela même
simultanément proposer à leurs cadets
l'on pense effectivement que nous en
aurions fini avec le l'angoissent du
baccalauréat depuis au moins 60 8 mai
bah je constate que la cet
investissement affectif que sur un
examen comme le baccalauréat témoigne
peut-être de cette espèce de deux prises
au sérieux du du savoir de la validation
du savoir eu égard alors savoir les
conditions ont été une dame à ménager
ceux qui font les pros d'histoire c'est
la bataille de cronenbourg 515 et ça
aide
d'autres encore une heure trente tout
doit être couché flou girafe c'est pas
fort non
dans l'entourage pas celle qui en plein
succès la plus pertinente
copie remise tout le monde s'est
retrouvé sur le quai pour la postérité
je crois que c'est l'idéal de la
philosophie d'entrer dans la vie
quotidienne et par le métro c'est la
voie la royale
quant à la notation elles restent à
l'usagé